hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the trailer
released at comic-con for The Walking
Dead Season six
I am fully caught up on The Walking Dead
so I'm actually gonna be aware of what's
sort of going on right now because I'm
I'm a cool nerd like that we both
started out in the same place
Thanks you can't come back from this I
know you can do people they always die
I'm a killer and you watching Rick
[Music]
people in here they've been inside from
the start they hadn't had to survive
they just don't get it they can't
I don't take chances anymore can you
sure
merci
[Music]
we'll make this work
[Music]
keep this place safe help us
keep our families safe so we're all
supposed to just fall in line behind you
[Music]
how many more of us have to die before
we do something which is dangerous these
people they're gonna take care of
themselves feel different about it yeah
I know we're like a stop we have to be
more scared
you should keep an eye on she's in
charge you're in charge now
the world isn't watching Carter watch it
all the way you are in but you still
know your way this is what life looks
like now we have to fight it if we don't
we die he's been out he's faced we are
going to trust him all of us
you choosing this life you will die
gotta get moving
you get the hell out of here and you
don't ever come back do you think you're
gonna take this community philosophy
from Darrell
[Music]
do you have any idea who you're talking
to
[Music]
[Music]
here's the deal you don't say [ __ ] and I
don't kill you do you think wow there's
a lot in that trailer there's a lot of
that trailer yet there's new elements
offer but there's a lot of very familiar
elements of The Walking Dead offered you
know they're always looking for a place
to essentially call it eyes a place to
call home which is usually a small
community Walker start coming in and
they want to protect the land but then
they really can't okay yeah we've all
seen that stuff before from The Walking
Dead what makes the Walking Dead
consistently different and consistently
feeling fresh is their honor of the
characters their characters are
constantly growing like if you just look
at Rick from season 1 to where he is now
totally different character the guy is
very much what you call traumatized the
trailers making it look like Rick and
Morgan are going against each other I
feel like that could just be a trailer
misleading us or just trying to steer us
in a different direction so they could
surprise us cuz they don't exactly show
a shot where it's clear that they're
going against each other but something
tells me that's not what's gonna
actually happen and they're making at
ease as if Daryl might die this season
Marketing decision not a good idea you
will lose a good 80% of your viewers if
you do that man or no that's the actual
percentage but you know it was pretty
high but Rick and Daryl you know Carol
is one of my favorites actually but Rick
and Daryl tend to be the two most
favorited ones the trailer really shows
that it's Rick's story and then at the
end they're teasing that Daryl has his
own story going on - so you got these
two stories of the two biggest
characters and you know they're making
it look like someone's trying to take
down Rick
and I know that Andrew Lincoln signed on
for six seasons so if Rick were to get
killed off it could happen now because
this is the sixth season like I said
earlier looks a little repetitive but
it's the walking dead and there's always
something there for me that feels fresh
and I'm always entertained even at the
show's boring moments I'm like I'd
rather be bored here than not doing
anything and you know someone dies every
season people die every season so who do
you want to die this season
please Dino everyone's gonna say Karl
but if you want to see Karl at least ask
someone else after that anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on social
networks such as Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine periscope and I think I
have a tumblr too I should probably
figure out what the login account
information as to that ldg otherwise
known as listen to Lindsey I have given
away your Facebook profile
congratulations seriously you're almost
at two hundred and K that is insanity
but also well-deserved I think once
you're ranking in that dough and have
enough to throw around fly my ass out
there so I can meet everyone and
obviously I want to get Veronica's
autograph she's going to be famous
someday and I just want to say that she
will be famous someday and I will ride
off of her fame Lindsey I want to be
known as Veronica six Stokes's boyfriend
for the rest of my life why are you
robbing me of that right and where is my
tag video Promises Promises you have
failed this friend okay so listen and
Lindsey is a youtuber she also has
another channel called horror horror
where she's a horror for horror movies
that she literally sells her body so she
can obtain horror movies so I gotta give
her if you want to have sex with her
apparently it's a horror movie so guys
I'm pretty sure most you can afford that
but horror Horrors of channels discusses
a lot of horror movies
she's type this in a video Jerry and I
film like an hour-long video of it but
then I accidentally lost some of the
footage so I never put the video
together but we did do that and we will
do it again around Halloween time
Lindsey so quit being a [ __ ] get off my
ass and wait for your [ __ ] video
Lindsey just back the [ __ ] up you're
pissing me off you're pissing me off
more importantly you're pissing off
Veronica
verónica he tell her how much Lindsay's
pissing you off I'm pissing you off
I'm kidding Lindsay you're a friend of
mine you know it